مرحبا منذ طاقه عرض مسلسل المكتب المقتبس
على سلسله الامريكيه والاراء حول العمل لا
زالت متباينه رغم انه الاعجاب بالعمل بشكل
عام اصبح واضح والسبب ارتفاع مشاهدات
العمل مع كل اسبوع جديد الجمهور الذي لا
زال متمسك بفكره وجوب التوقف عن اقتباس
الافكار الناجحه الاجنبيه هو الابرز في
المشهد واللي يصير على مقارنه كل شيء
بالنسخه اللي تم الاقتباس منها بينما هناك
جمهور اخر لم يشاهد العمل الامريكي من قبل
وهو الذي يرى المكتب عملا جميلا يستحق
المشاهده
النسخه الامريكيه فمن الطبيعي انهم راح
يقارورون بشكل لا ارادي لانه في مشاهد
ماخوذه الطاقه بالتمثيل لمسلسل المكتب
بشكل عام حلو واثني هنا على صالح ابو عمره
صالح ابو عمره وفق بشكل كبير جدا في اداء
هذا الدور
[موسيقى]
عن العمل على جزء ثاني من مسلسل مدرسه
الروابي للبنات واللي يحقق نجاح كبير على
مستوى الوطن العربي تجاوز حدود الاردن الى
الخليج ومصر وغيرها من الدول العربيه
والجمهور يطرح اسئله كثيره عن الطريقه
اللي راح يرجع بها العمل وعن الابطال
والفكره وماذا كان راح يتم الخروج من حدود
المدرسه وبيوت الطالبات الى مساحات ابعد
كواليس الثقه الشوملي مخرجات وكاتبه العمل
اللي جابك على بعض هذه التسامح في اشياء
كثير جديده وفي اشياء كثير حلوه ومفاجاه
كبيره
بالسيزن الثاني وان شاء الله عم ناخذ
السيزون الاول اعتبرته كتجربه الاولى اليه
هلا بالموسم الثاني حاسه يعني رح ندخل
بعمق اكبر وراح نحكي عن مواضيع اكثر واا
ارجعنا بريك نيو جراوند ان شاء الله
اه
لحظه
كثير اول شيء هذا كثير بيجيب لي الفخر انه
اييه من المسلسل من مدرسه الروابي البنات
لقوا حياته ثانيه لقوا حياه جديده وانفتحت
لهم مجلات كبيره فكيف احافظ على الروح
اللي هو
اصلا همم
فهذا الشيء ابدا ما راح يروح من عندهم همم
ان شاء الله بس ما بقدر احكي لك تفاصيل
اكتر حاليا لانه في مفاجاه جديده كمان ههه
اذا استديو عشان تشوفي احنا حاليا في
مرحله ما قبل الانتاج يعني عم نحضر هلا في
التحضيرات يعني ان شاء الله التحضيرات
النهائيه قبل التصوير
اصله نسيتها الاعلام المرئي والمسموع
قائمتها عن الافلام الاكثر اقبالا على
الشباك السينمائي السعودي حيث جاءت خاليه
تماما من الافلام العربيه وتصدر استلر
ريشه القائمه بين ما جاء فيلبوسي بوت
لاستوش في المركز الثالث وقد علمنا في
كواليس انه خلال الايام القادمه لم يتم
طرح اي افلام عربيه جديده في السينمات
لحين موعد راس السنه وهو موسم طبعا
وتتلخص المبررات حول الغياب الافلام
العربيه عن الشباك بحسب الموزعين الى
التخوف من طرح اي افلام حتى نهايه مونديال
2022 وكمان حلول موسم راس السنه عشان
تشتعل المنافسه العربيه السينمائيه من جسم
نتوقف الان مع جديد النجوم ما بين
التحضيرات لبدا التصوير دراما رمضان
ومسلسلات قريبه للمنصات والتعاقد على
افلام لعيد الفطر
بيتكلم عن بطوله القوات الجويه في محاربه
الارهاب عندي فيلم يوم 13 ده فيلم هارون
اول فيلم ثري دي ثري
دينا الشربيني واحمد
داوودتين
واحده نلحق قبل نهايه العام وان شاء الله
في اغاني بقيه القلب وتنزل على مدار عام
20 23 وعندي في المئه للانتاج ان شاء الله
فيلم اولاد حريم كريم السعوديه
ثاني طبعا ف- اا فمتحمسه انا اول مسلسل
يبقى مسلسل مهم وضخمه زي ده وهو من اعمال
الام بي سي وان شاء الله هتعرض في رمضان
عندي مسلسل اسمه العالم دبليو بنصوره
حاليا همم ده مسلسل سوبر هيروز لعربي او
المسلسل سوبر هيروز عربي جاد مش كوميدي
معايا في حماده هلال ومحمد الشرنوبي ومحمد
لطفي ومجموعه كبيره اخراج ياسين حسن
وانتاج سيفي ان شاء الله راح يكون عندي
فيلم في عام 20 23 وكمان مسلسل في رمضان
باللهجه المصريه وقريبا ان شاء الله
مسلسلات
وانا ان شاء الله عندي راح يكون في رمضان
دفعت لندن مسلسل كذبه ابريل حاليا ما اقدر
اتكلم عنها لكن
الهرم اثنين ما في شارع الهرم اثنين
كثير
لانه همم
[موسيقى]